I know they're gonna be people that try
to claim that Coraline isn't a horror
movie and therefore I can't cover it
here on my horror channel and I just
like to remind those people before we
get started here a few of the things
that happen in Coraline roll the clips
yeah horror movie they're also
references to a couple of the most well
known horror movies of all time so stick
around to the end of this video if you
want to hear about them
before we get into the truly creepy
stuff there are a few things you missed
at the beginning of the movie where the
filmmakers just couldn't help but
calling attention to themselves
scorelines family is moving into their
new home with the help of the ranch
brothers moving company and we end up
seeing the ranch brothers whose name
tags read Jerome in jail this is a
reference to the real-life ranch
brothers who are a pair of character
sculptors in many great animated films
and while they don't sculpt plenty
characters in Coraline they did work on
director Henry sell its previous top
motion film James in the Giant Peach so
naturally they graffiti the word stopped
no rules on their own truck and when Joe
receives a tip for his moving services
the photo of George Washington on the
bill has been replaced by that of
director Henry Selick
the moving truck is also green and the
first time we see it it's pulled up next
to the house which is covered in pink in
the novella one of the things that
Coraline finds off-putting about the
other world beyond the door is the way
that her bedroom is painted in shades of
green and pink but the movie does a
great job of showing us how Coraline
found her world to be dreary and boring
in ways that the novella was not able to
take these two scenes in the garden for
example where the real world is made to
look damp in devoid of color while the
other world is bursting with life and
colors the film also introduces details
that the novella lacks like the fact
that her parents in the real world are
gardeners or at least they write about
gardening and her other mother is
eventually revealed to be a predatory
like insect creature insects are the
natural enemy of gardeners throughout
the movie you can spot plenty of clues
pointing to this insect motif and like
her two sets of parents most of them
come in pairs examples include the
dragonfly pin on Coraline tear and the
dragonfly decorations over her bed a
mantis tractor that her other father
ride and the Mantis picture-frame holder
by Coraline
but the fact that the family drives a
Volkswagen Beetle and the chocolate
beetles that her other mother snacks on
and the picture of the boy in the other
drawing room is in a spider picture
frame and coralline ends up fighting the
other mother on a giant spider web I
also think there's something to be said
about the fact that the other mother
created this world as a trap to capture
Coraline soul it's not a big world but
as one line in the book puts it spiders
webs only have to be large enough to
catch flies she crafted this world and
tries to trap Coraline by sewing
together the doll as bait and she sews
buttons onto the eyes of all of her
victims so there's a comparison to be
made with spiders who weave their webs
from a string in a very similar manner
and of course her final form most
closely resembles a giant spider and
that's not the first time we covered
something like that I also found an
interesting piece of text on her
father's computer screen right before
Coraline accidentally turns off the
power if you pause at just the right
moment it reads everything is smelling
like success from out of the Cove a
slime colored blob crawls out of your
compost containing something falls to
the ground it reminds me a lot of the
scariest scene from the book where
Coraline discovers an underground cellar
which she commons has a strange smell
and finds a creature that had almost no
features on its face which had puffed
and swollen like Risen bread dough there
seem to be a lot of similarities between
these two descriptions we soon find out
that the other mother is in control of
everything in the other world she's
referred to as a beldam
down BBC which traces back to an old
French word meaning old woman or which
Coraline has to fight witchcraft with
witchcraft she uses this stone which is
known in our world as an adder stone or
witch stone to locate the ghost
children's eyes and at the beginning of
the movie she uses a branch of poison
oak as a dowsing rod and her neighbor YB
accuses her of witchcraft I heard about
water witching before but it doesn't
make sense I mean it's your small branch
we're first given the idea that the
beldum is in control when Coraline meets
her other father and he plays her a song
on the piano but the piano was the one
controlling him not the other way around
it does this by taking control of his
hands and the other mother's hands being
in control becomes another motif seen
time and time again in the movie the
reason for this is because in the
novella when Coraline and the other
mother make the wager other mother
agrees to let Coraline go if she wins
and swears on her mother's grave that
she'll keep her word but that's not good
enough for Coraline so she also swears
on her right hand and there are a ton of
references to that hand in the movie
when Coraline discovers the other worlds
garden other father has this to say
mother said you'd like it
or she knows him like the back of her
hand there are also several close-ups of
other mother's hands throughout the
movie even before her hand is detached
we also see several other images that
resemble the true form of other mothers
hands like the lightning strike outside
the window clouds that parch to reveal
the moon after her defeat and the tea
leaves that miss spanks interprets as a
sign of danger in coral lands tea on the
contrary is forcible brings the tea
leaves upside down and sees them as a
giraffe which may be a clue about her
eventually becoming trapped in the other
world where there's a giraffe toy in
kora lines room or maybe it's actually a
clue about the true form of her enemy
whose neck extends like that of a
giraffe
or maybe it's actually a clue about
where Cora lines parents are hid in the
snow globe from the zoo because you're
after an animal that you'd find at the
zoo I don't know it's got to be one of
those okay Cora lines main quest in the
movie is to retrieve the eyes for the
three ghost children and find her
parents
and although Coraline never knew that
any children had gone missing in the
house until later there are some clues
early on in the movie actually the first
thing we see is the repurposing of the
doll resembling mrs. Lovat sister then
when Coraline explores the house on the
rainy day she discovers what she calls a
painfully boring portrait of the little
boy who seems to be the ghost boy that
once lived back
one boring blue boy in a painfully
boring painting and finally other mother
has pictures of three children on her
own kitchen two girls and one boy just
like the three goats in the book core
lines favorite hobby is being an
explorer and that's true in the movie as
well the carpet in the drawing room is
an image of a compass another difference
from the book is in the clothes that
Coraline changes into in the other realm
in the movie it's a shirt with stars on
it after sending the other mother's hand
down the well Coraline has the following
thought about the star someone had once
told her that if you look up at the sky
from the bottom of a mine shaft even in
the brightest of daylight you see a
night sky and star Coraline wondered if
the hand could see stars from where it
was supposed to be so deep if he fell
the bottom looked up you see a sky field
stars in the middle of the day some
Coraline wears that shirt while she's
trapped in the other realm her situation
is bleak just like being stuck at the
bottom of the well now if all of this
was not enough horror for you then let
me point out a couple of horror movie
references that I found in Coraline the
first is pretty obscured but the chair
and Coraline other room has the same
design as Jack Torrance's chair from The
Shining the other can be spotted after
she escapes from the other world where
her father is playing with the squid toy
on her bed in exactly the same way that
the facehugger xenomorph attacks its
victims in aioli
[Music]
and if that doesn't convince you that
this is a horror movie
I don't know what well so that covers
the movie adaptation of Coraline but
there's so much more to analyze in the
story so coming up on horror history
I'll be covering the scariest details
that were left out of the movie as I
talked about Coraline Jones and Justin
love you don't want to miss out on that
so make sure you subscribe to seize
these worlds for new Horrors every week
bring that death belt for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]